Oh God Wow I I can't even process that
let alone answer it be honest everyone
in London is pretty nervous this morning
after Oh what the [ __ ] man everyone in
London is pretty nervous this morning
after an historic vote that resulted in
the United Kingdom leaving the European
Union once and for all but we wanted to
see what they're more nervous about and
then depend in Britain or Donald Trump
eventually becoming president States of
America that's the one so we've been
asking people sort of a silly question
we have a lot of Americans somebody
watching my question for you is what are
you more nervous about the brexit or
Donald Trump becoming president Oh
Donald Trump easy
I would rather Donald Trump presidency
then brakes it because it's Donald Trump
becoming president
there still are checks and balances on
him and there's also a limit in time so
it's only four years where's this
Britain leaving the EU that really is
much more permanent damage Donald Trump
becoming president of the United States
Oh
Trump all the way all the way that is
terrifying you see if they both happen
now like what are we all doomed we're
all doomed
I don't know if you Americans realized
how much we actually know about your
politics and Republicans and Democrats
the idea of him being president is
terrifying to be honest I think they're
both incredibly frightening yeah what do
you think will happen if he does become
president with the brexit already
happening I think if we have Trump Boris
Johnson and Putin we might as well just
sit and drink beer and wait for it all
to fall apart we'll have a great laugh
in the meantime but it won't last long
will it and that will be the end of the
world
can I ask where you remain or leave I
didn't vote oh no no your yo person you
have to vote oh did you have a good
reason for not voting